you get a trump and why do people like
Trump so much is because he's finally
somebody who he's talked a long time
about running and saying he wouldn't do
it I remember that interview back in the
day with I think it was Oprah and he's
like you know I wouldn't run but if I
did hear the things that I would focus
on and he finally decides he is going to
run and it it feels like I think to a
lot of people it's the first time
someone who should run is actually
running despite his his crass
personality you know he's a guy who is
not supposed to be the politician the
politicians all wear the same suits
they'll talk the same way they all
Pander to the same same in the same ways
Hillary Clinton shows up in you know
whatever state with a fake southern
accent AOC shows up to a rallying as a
fake Puerto Rican Latina thing listen
it's fake it's
sure he might be rude but people kind of
feel like
we keep asking for people to run for
office who are real people who actually
care
and they don't want to do it why would
you it's it's torture